sparring or whatever yeah but I never
had this feeling of intimidation it's
always been a playground because I'm
there to play with my friends and check
out girls yeah so like I'm like oh let's
go to the gym like there's hot girls and
then like maybe we could talk to them
and then it's like oh let's go there and
lift some stuff so like I never really
had this negative association so it was
difficult for me to empathize and
understand because I remember I would
invite people to barbell and then
they're like Nam intimidated and why
everyone there's nice yeah and then I
would be like kind of hurt because I'm
like what you don't want to go with me
and play like it's almost like I'm
inviting them to Chuck E Cheese and they
don't want to come with you yeah yeah
yeah and I'm like why like what are you
afraid of like people there are really
[ __ ] nice oh for sure when i when i
some some of my friends for sacramento
they want to come out and they want to
work out i'm like well we can go to
barbell right and you can come with me
and then you could meet bharden these
are like close friends yeah and they got
nah man it's gonna be too crazy I was
like it's a [ __ ] gym you work out how
are the [ __ ] you want
yeah you know and I always have people
who remind them that barbell is probably
one of the nicest [ __ ] gyms I've ever
been to in my life
more so than 24-hour Fitness do 24 hours
have they have a lot of douche bags that
go there yeah I don't like guys yeah
those years are the [ __ ] worst like
when guys are peacocking
yeah like I'm just like man like why are
you putting on a show like just get out
of here I want to work out like stop
hogging the machine let me tell you this
[ __ ] story man
I was I used to go to 24-hour out in
South Pasadena late at night um there's
just not a lot of people there so
there's one [ __ ] guy I'm you know I'm
not benching a lot I just had a 45 and a
25 on there I'm a guy as I'm benching
and I put it down the guy comes up and
he just takes my 25 pound that happens
all the time yeah that's so [ __ ]
ready to get up and I just [ __ ]
snatch it out of his hand I'm like the
[ __ ] are you doing man and he goes like
oh you set it down I was like does it
look like I'm [ __ ] done with this you
know and obviously people are looking
around like he's a [ __ ] dumbass and
he's looking at me like I did something
wrong you know what I mean a nice type
of environment too that I think people
get intimidated at gyms because if
people like that dude what a [ __ ]
that's a guy that's never been punched
in the [ __ ] head
etiquette yeah there's the route that is
so rude like there's no other plates
there yeah and by the way why was this
Jack guy he would have never done that
yeah there so it was he huh what was he
like
so Nicky I'm like the different world if
I was his jacked human being and I
didn't look like this goofy asian guy I
guarantee you he would have never done
that that's the same [ __ ] guy that
was in the Ikea parking lot yes you know
and it's just it's kind of odd when I
look at that situation and it does make
sense why people get intimidated
these guys are in a [ __ ] ball yeah
[ __ ] beats by draping like he's
living in his own world also is not that
cool to work out must be so hard to work
hell yeah and in my mind too like the
only thing I'm thinking about is you
know you may be buffer than me but if I
throw a 45 pound pound plate at your
[ __ ] teeth your muscles will do [ __ ]
you know and I just you know it's just
enraging and I'm just sitting there just
like what are you doing obviously other
people at the gym we're dogging him to
like what the [ __ ] are you doing guy
yeah so here's a bad rap [ __ ] so and
I as a grown up I told him you should've
dude I told one of staff members about
this jack isn't they kicked them out
that night because you're like [ __ ]
[ __ ] bro that is the rudest ever
yeah do you hear about that there was a
story that was like a long time ago but
it was a kid was deadlifting and some
dude oh yes strapped you like shoved
them and you're like oh dude you're a
piece of [ __ ] you screw this long video
the other guy dealt with a kid that was
deadlift making some waiting hit him
while he was dead lifting yeah so while
he was strapped in yeah strap his foot
on it and he slanted that's what it was
yeah yeah what a [ __ ] prick I forgot
I think he was saying he was too loud or
he was banging his yeah [ __ ] off bro
guys never deadlift in his life pal
didn't even work at the gym yeah he
didn't even wear he wasn't even a seven
her self righteous crazy guy because in
his mind he's [ __ ] like oh this is
gym etiquette yeah but it's like nah
dude sometimes when you're lifting heavy
weight and you're thrown some weight
around
plates are gonna slam against the floor
I'm sorry cuz it's such an odd thing to
even in my case when that guy took the
weight off let's just say for example he
thought that I was done with my set you
should have asked me yeah you could've
came up to me hey man all you like
everybody else does in the gym yeah dude
there's there only two plates yeah it's
a 24-hour fitness they'll have more
plates elsewhere
back figure I guarantee you he's the
kind of guy that will sue you if you
smack off the work that was so
unwarranted because he was trying to be
a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude yeah
I'm just like trying to Punk me or
something or whatever and mind you -
it's like passive-aggressive weirdness
it's such a [ __ ] move it's like either
[ __ ] kill me or don't do it at all
that's my philosophy like he that's so
[ __ ] this is how I feel - I feel like
he he took the plate and he assumed that
I wasn't gonna say anything yeah you
know that's the other [ __ ] up and it
makes me feel really small
he thought he can get away with yeah so
you know when I got up and I snatched it
out of his hand I bet she was like oh
[ __ ] what up what's my next move it's
like well your next move is either
you're gonna [ __ ] swing at me or
what's gonna guess what he's gonna tell
on you and I guess what I did I [ __ ]
like you're an adult now David you know
I don't who what's the point you know
I'm not gonna do he was kind of but the
other thing was it was causing a
commotion because other people were
giving him [ __ ] - I was like well [ __ ] I
call the staff member over and then I
told him I kill this guy [ __ ] just
snatch the weight out of my barbell yeah
and the guy got kicked out but it's just
the concept that somebody could do that
to you for no [ __ ] what was the
reason and I think that's what begins me
frustrated - I can't figure out his
logic like why did you do it I think
it's more like you should have trouble
dude yeah you go trippin I don't know
like this is what I always wonder to do
why people bully each other this way
because every culture bullies each other
in different ways right or do they feel
like like you know like I think I think
when it comes to bullying they attack or
treat people weird
like they they bully those that they
think they could have won over yeah and
I feel like man bullying happens in
Asian culture but not like that
yeah it's very different right so it
blindsides me like what's going on here
now mind you I have been punked at a
24-hour - it was the k-town one there's
there's a k-town when there's some
[ __ ] precarious people and they're
sometimes I don't know now but this is
why I lived in k-town back of the day
but the way the guy punked it was very
thug like so I disrespected his thuggish
I was on a lat pulldown machine I think
I was like yo that's my machine ass like
damn straight it is yes
bullying I understand cuz it's like some
thug [ __ ] you know man you know [ __ ]
bolo yeung ya [ __ ] Chong Li from yeah
he's a boy at the gym
oh I respect it cuz he's a [ __ ] maniac
like you'll come up and he doesn't even
say can I have you'll be working out and
he'll go huh alright I know what that
means that's my [ __ ] iris I honestly
would respect that is more than someone
taking a [ __ ] plate walking on a
passive-aggressive you mean it's like
[ __ ] [ __ ] if he came up and then he was
like get off it's my turn I would have
been like yes sir yeah but if he does if
he just pulls the weight off I'm like
what am I supposed to do am I supposed
to fight like I don't understand don't
put me in this situation
yeah like I don't understand this
communication like like I don't know man
it's from here it's just more Larry
weird I feel like if we if we just
boiled it down as if you're not about
that life and don't [ __ ] neck like oh
right because that do wasn't about that
type of life the other guy that punked
me said oh that's my machine he's about
that life I'm gonna get up and move and
obviously even the people around us knew
yo that's his machine don't [ __ ]
touch that [ __ ] right it's like it's
like church bullying was worse than when
I get bullied by white people it's weird
and then so I'm like okay well how did
they how do they deal with this and how
do they battle it out cuz I'm so far
removed from that culture I want to
understand because it's like a Jedi mind
trick it's not what's going on I feel
I'm just [ __ ] flabbergasted yeah [ __ ]
like it makes me like you guys gotta
find a new gym yeah why don't go to that
24 hour at all so it's its way and you
know also to you you know just to put it
in perspective I mean I'm there at 1:00
a.m. to him there's a lot of weirdos at
that time yeah so when you're with a
bunch the weirdo time you're gonna meet
a lot of weird people like I had this
other [ __ ] soaked leaf and I used to
work at 24 hour that 24 hour in the
morning and there was a width out
[ __ ] failed this roided-out Beachbody
buff guy right with this big fake titted
girlfriend and they would scream and
fight every morning that's dope I kid
you not you could even add up when I
have Cleveland tell the story cuz he
could explain it better but it was to
the point where they would do a workout
and without fail Khalifa's like watch
they're gonna fight again and they would
do some [ __ ] like this I'm not
remembering uh verbatim but it would be
something on some [ __ ] like
I told you to [ __ ] do it this way why
are you doing it that way I'm trying my
best with the [ __ ] yell at me they
just [ __ ] do that way and then she
starts crying and he will come up he go
baby I'm so sorry
I'm sorry I'm like dude they definitely
have crazy sex or he beats her or some
[ __ ] that's how I trained my client
it was crazy though but his staff never
said keep it down or anything I mean I
this was in the morning so it's pretty
heavy you know but the guy would just
scream at her and the she cries and he
starts kissing or apologizing but it was
the same uncomfortable space that's
abuse that's some abuse that's a beer so
you know just to wrap it back I can
understand why people are intimidated at
gyms yeah commercial gyms yeah that's
true cuz barbell is like a it's like a
community like everyone kind of knows
each other yeah yeah and there's a lot
of respect because people just go in and
do their work
I used to even be so nervous when I was
like in my when I first started signed
up for 24 a night like early 20 rounds
18 I how did you sign up I signed I just
went to the place and I signed